Chris Mannix who covers the Association
hi Chris how are you what happened well
let me start with these comments with
the NBA executives saying he's killed
their chemistry and also with the
comments of if you can't deal with these
distractions then you shouldn't be in
Los Angeles well I think with the
chemistry question and I've heard this
from from various people over the last
it really since amputee gave his trade
demand became public it's not hard in
fact it's almost expected for some of
the young players in that locker room
who came into the season believing that
you know LeBron wanted to kind of grow
with them to build a winner with them
all of a sudden you have LeBron say I'd
love to play with Anthony Davis you have
Anthony Davis we've represented by
LeBrons agent trying to orchestrate a
deal to the Lakers and you have the
Lakers trade offers becoming very public
it's got hard for them to to look at
this and say well he doesn't want us
here and that they have that adversely
affect the chemistry within that locker
room so it's not like LeBron is going in
there and saying you know these guys are
all terrible but if you connect the dots
a little bit it's easy to see how the
players can feel like he doesn't fully
believe in them yeah and I could
understand there's a little bit of
unrest in there and there is a lack of
chemistry there if I know that that guy
wanted me traded now I know I got to be
a professional but that guy was gonna
trade me once Anthony Davis in here if
I'm Luke Walton I know that my days are
numbered as well this is because LeBron
brought this attention and distraction
to Los Angeles nobody else did he did it
and I think that you know take ownership
of that take blame of that and this is
when I want a great player to be great
you don't lose to Memphis
you're not losing to New Orleans without
Anthony Davis you know this this is more
alarming than it been it should be at
this time of the year yeah and look the
Memphis game in particular
LeBron needs to take ownership that I
mean he put up a very kind of Westbrook
eonline there
was 8 for 23 from the floor
you know just was inefficient all the
way around his defense hasn't been good
all season long and this the schedule
advantage you know not good for the
Lakers coming down the strikes here
these are the games they have to win to
get themselves even a puncher's chance
of getting back into the playoff mix
without those wins I think it's going to
be a heart heart hill for the quad
Reggie Miller said yesterday that he
thinks it's better for the Lakers not to
make the playoffs and my point is making
the playoffs is about Magic Johnson and
LeBron James or LeBron James and Magic
Johnson it's it's a pride factor more
than anything else what do you think
about making the playoffs are not making
the plants what's best I think there's
something to all that but I do think
that making the playoffs if you're
looking to make a deal this offseason
with the pelicans making the playoffs
and gives your young players another
platform another chance to prove
themselves now one of the things that
people look at the Boston assets in a
davis trade and say well jaylen Browns
numbers are down this year Tara Rose
years numbers are down this year both
those guys were terrific in the playoffs
last year Jim Brown averaged 18 points
per game in a plasterer Tarot's year was
maybe the second best point guard in the
Eastern Conference playoffs last year
making the playoffs
you know the pride value but it also
gives it has you know real tangible
value and kind of showcasing these
players for a potential deal and I
started to look at that with it feels
like you could get Jalen Brown you could
get Tatum you could get Rozier and maybe
their draft pick from Memphis in and
that feels like that might be a better
deal for New Orleans and maybe New
Orleans has made up their mind they're
just not trading Anthony Davis to the
Lakers I I'm not you would know better
than I would but if I'm if I'm a free
agent I'm looking at what's going on
with the Lakers this isn't attractive at
all yeah it's this offseason I mean I
don't think you could understate just
how important it is for the Lakers
because if they don't get a guy you have
to spin forward a little bit dudette I
mean look at the summer of 2020 if they
don't get a guy in 2019
maybe they can lure Anthony Davis in
2020 but that's a risk because he may
sign with the team that acquires him
other than that you're looking at
draymond Green you're looking at a bunch
of restricted guys and you're looking
LeBron age 36 season and wondering how
are we going to put together a winner
around them I'm with you on the the free
agent stuff
and that's why we have never talked
about and I have never heard the top
level guys the guys that are out there
right now this summer
none of them are listing the Lakers as
their top choice it's quiet and the
Clippers are the Raptors you know Kevin
Durant certainly seems earmarked for
their Golden State or the Knicks it's
it's gonna be challenging for the for
Magic Johnson to put together a winning
team around LeBron the next couple of
years we were looking at James Harden
streak of 30 consecutive or you know
points per game averaging at least 30 a
game and it ended at 32 and then all of
a sudden you realized wilted it's 65
consecutive games why is it we don't
recognize Wilt Chamberlain the way we
recognize Babe Ruth that that there you
know there's a like they're not real a
mythical figure but we recognize the
greatness of Babe Ruth we forget about
Wilt Chamberlain I think whether it's
fair or not one thing we say about Wilt
is that he was almost like a character
out of Gulliver's Travels right like
he's this super-sized athletes whereas
everybody else around him outside of
Bill Russell was a smaller player
playing almost a different sport I think
we are looking at will as this this is
being overpowering we're as we look at
Babe Ruth as being maybe more skilled
yeah it's I don't know if I agree with
it I mean I love my career that much I
think we'll accomplishments personally
should be I'm with you I think whilst
accomplishments are but I you know when
when this conversation comes up it's
like well what was this 7-foot one
monster and how many other guys were
able to defend him on a sheer physical
level that seems to be the argument yeah
but it's same with Shaq nobody could you
know come close to his size on Ewing in
Elijah water guy
that were you know not sacks size but
comparable they can go back to the days
of will cream how many guys were even
close she was physically overpower we
talked about Russell being his peer
Russell like six times like you know
with a great defensive instincts and
skills but he was nowhere near as
physically big as well either yeah but
you had guys who were big nate thurmond
was a very good defensive player Walt
Bellamy and you know I had guys who were
similar size or at least close to it but
I don't know I just feel like we we look
at Wilton go I don't even know how I
categorize him what he did you know and
the fact that we don't have video when
he scored a hundred points in a game did
it really happen you know it's one of
those where did he do we really land on
the moon type thing and we have video of
that I mean most people only know wills
hundred point game from that you know
that that piece of paper he held oh yeah
become a meme on the internet where
everybody just kind of changes it what
Ben Simmons goes for one they erased the
zeros if one offensive and I mean
honestly like most people know that will
did it but they don't have any context
of how it did it
are you buying into the Rockets now this
late run beating Golden State again
without harden when we get to the
playoffs oh I'm buying in not to say
that they're there they're they're going
to win but I think they're back on that
level that they were last you know the
defensive numbers were trouble me
they're not a very good defensive team
right now whereas last year they were in
the top half of the league defensively
but you know forget hard and forget Paul
the reason this team is back on a
championship radar are those
bargain-basement additions that made dad
I mean Kenneth Faried is given them like
16 and 10 Kenneth Faried was stapled to
that Nets bench and has been a shell of
himself the last few years
Austin Rivers was let go basically by
two teams this year and now he's given
them 33 minutes per game this team had a
bad offseason in Los Teresa they lost
but bob bootay
they lost some of their defensive
identity you know in the process in
getting for reading rivers some of the
other guys that they've been able to
grow they're starting to get some of
that swagger back so I think you can
count on Chris Paul and James Harden
being great if they're healthy but
you're now able to count on the
all players being a lot better than they
were at the start of the season good to
visit with you Chris safe travels thanks
for joining us you don't even want to
talk about the Celtics I mean I'm
disappointed in that debt I assumed it'd
be some Celtic related conversation if
you're a betting man as Kyrie Irving
with the Celtics next year yes five
years 190 million dollars I'm a betting
man
else are the Celtics better this year
with Hayward back in Kyrie back than
they were last year I think they I think
they're more capable of winning a
championship with this group are they
better yeah
the ceiling the ceiling is higher let's
say it that way but are they better or
not better till they do it last year's
team did yeah I mean if if they if they
get to the Conference Finals they'll be
a couple but it's like Dan this the
Celtics team is most maddening players
I've covered in a while like they will
lose Chicago they beat by 56 like six
weeks ago but then they'll probably go
out tonight and beat Toronto so going to
try to win there's a three no against
the Sixers they've been good against all
the talk to your team's and kind of bad
against a lot of the bottom feeders so
that's why I said the ceiling is higher
it wouldn't surprise anybody to see them
go on a run and win the entire Eastern
Conference just like it wouldn't
surprise anybody to see them win the
three feet and loose the Nets in the
first round thank you Chris you got a
dip that's Chris Mannix he's a senior
basketball writer from Sports
Illustrated NBC Sports Boston NBA
analyst Dan Patrick show brought to you
by the great folks at AMG Mercedes if
you missed any of our interviews from
the Mercedes AMG man cave go to the Dan
Patrick show app where you can watch and
listen from inside the Mercedes AMG
mancave Mercedes AMG driving performance
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
you